so we are interested in studying the
relationship between the amount that
folks study for tests and their score on
a test where the score is between 0 & 6
and so what we're going to do is go look
at the people who took the tests we're
going to plot for each person the amount
that they studied and their score so for
example this data point is someone who
studied an hour and they got a 1 on the
test and then we're going to fit a
regression line and this blue regression
line is the actual regression line for
these four data points and here is the
equation for that regression line now
there's a couple of things to keep in
mind normally when you're doing this
type of analysis you would do it with
far more than four data points the
reason why I kept this to four is
because we're actually going to
calculate how good a fit this regression
line is by hand and typically you would
not do it by hand we have computers for
that now the way that we're going to
measure how good a fit this regression
line is to the data has several names
one name is the standard deviation of
the residuals another name is the
root-mean-square deviation sometimes
abbreviated rmsd
sometimes it's called root mean square
error so what we're going to do is is
for every point we're going to calculate
the residual and then we're going to
square it and then we're going to add up
the sum of those squared residuals so
we're going to take the sum of the
residuals residuals squared and then
we're going to divide that by the number
of data points we have
minus 2 and we can talk in future videos
or are more advanced to test this class
of why you divide by 2 but it's related
to the idea that what we're calculating
here is a statistic and we're trying to
estimate a true parameter as best as
possible and n minus 2 actually does the
trick for us but to calculate the root
mean squared deviation we would then
take a square root of this and some of
you might recognize strong parallels
between this and how we calculate it
sample standard deviation early in our
statistics career and I encourage
you to think about it but let's actually
calculate it by hand as I mentioned
earlier in this video to see how things
actually play out so to do that I'm
going to give ourselves a little table
here so let's say that is our x value in
that column let's make this our Y value
let's make this Y hat which is going to
be equal to 2.5 X minus 2 and then let's
make this the residual squared which is
going to be our Y value minus our Y hat
value our actual minus our estimate for
that given x squared and then we're
going to sum them all up divided by n
minus 2 and take the square root
so first let's do this data point so
that's the point 1 comma 1 1 comma 1 now
what is the estimate from our regression
line well for that x value when X is
equal to 1 it's going to be 2.5 times 1
minus 2 so it's going to be 2.5 times 1
minus 2 which is equal to 0.5 and so our
residual squared is going to be 1 minus
0.5 1 minus 0.5 squared which is equal
to that's going to be 0.5 squared which
is going to be 0.25 all right let's do
the next data point we have this one
right over here it is 2 comma 2 now our
estimate form the regression line when x
is equals 2 when x equals 2 is going to
be equal to 2.5 times our x value times
2 minus 2 which is going to be equal to
3 and so our residual squared is going
to be 2 minus 3 2 minus 3 squared which
is negative 1 squared which is going to
be equal to 1 then we can go to this
point so that's the point 2 comma 3 2
comma 3
now our estimate from our regression
line is going to be 2 point 5 times our
x value times 2 minus 2 which is going
to be equal to
three and so our residual here is going
to be zero and you can see that that
point sits on the regression line so
it's going to be three minus three three
minus three squared which is equal to
zero and then last but not least we have
this point right over here when X is
three our Y value this person studied
three hours and they got a six on the
test so Y is equal to six and so our
estimate from the regression line you
could say what you wouldn't expect it to
get based on that aggression line is two
point five times our x value times three
minus two is equal to five point five
and so our residual squared is six minus
five point five squared minus five point
five squared so it's point five squared
which is zero point two five so now the
next step let me take the sum of all of
these squared residuals so this is let
me just write it this way let me just do
it like this so the sum of the residuals
residuals squared is equal to if I just
sum all of this up it's going to be
point it's going to be one point five
one point five and then if I divide that
by n minus two so if I divide by n minus
two that's going to be equal to I have
four data points so I'm going to divide
by four minus two so I'm going to divide
by two and then I'm going to want to
take the square root of that and then we
want to take the square root of that and
so this is going to get us one point
five over two is the same thing as 3/4
so it's the square root of 3/4 or the
square root of three over two and you
could use a calculator to figure what
that is
to figure out what that is as a decimal
but this gives us a sense of how good a
fit this regression line is The Closer
this is to zero the better the fit of
the regression line the further away
from 0 the worse fit and what would be
the units for the root mean squared
deviation well it would be in terms of
whatever your units are for your y axis
in this case it would be the score on
the test and that's one of the other
values of this
calculation of taking the square root of
the sum of the squares of the residuals
dividing by n minus 2